[Musique]
et combien votre lait 3,86 vous savez
que c'est on soude plus que ce que la
régie permet pour une troisième fois en
17 ans l'épicerie a fait enquête sur le
prix du lait conventionnel
alors ici en de payer notre deux lettres
2% 3 85 soit 10 de plus que ce que
permet la régie en plus le prix n'était
posée
nous avons principalement acheté délais
dans des dépanneurs indépendants à
montréal québec et en région pour une
troisième fois
on a malheureusement trouvé des fautifs
cette fois ci près de la moitié des
commerces visités ne respectent pas les
prix réglementaire je vois pas le prix
droit et 85 s'est dissout de plus que ce
que vous avez le droit de vendre la
délinquance au niveau des prix minimums
maximum mais par la régie c'est quelque
chose qui est pas nouveau
malheureusement on est venu faire un
saut du côté de québec on a visité deux
quartiers et dans un de ces deux
quartiers 75 % des commerces visités
étaient fautifs et ça varie beaucoup
par exemple dans une épicerie un du
litre de lait écrémé et vendu 400 de
plus un peu plus loin sur le bord de
l'autoroute en région on a même payé 40
cents de plus que le prix maximum permis
pour un litre de lait 2 % nous avons
aussi vérifier les sites internet des
grandes chaînes d'alimentation un seul
fautif
wal mart alors on a reçu les qui sur le
site internet de walmart ne respectait
pas la loi sur les prix minimum et
maximum délais alors juste par exemple
seul hélas affiche est affiché à 9 cents
de plus que ce que la loi permet et
celui ci pour un litre seulement 66 ou
de plus que ce que la loi permet sylvain
charlebois professeur en distribution et
politiques agroalimentaires au niveau du
détail c'est québec et c'est la seule
province qui règlemente le prix du lait
au détail par le biais de la régie
des marchés agricoles au québec il ya un
prix plafond et plancher au québec les
gens le savent pas je lui demande à
n'importe qui dans la rue quel est le
prix minimum et maximum pour un doublé
de la 2% jeu pour certains que les gens
vont vous répondre mais je suis pas
certain qu'ils vont pouvoir vous dire
prix approximatif d'adultes de parce que
c'est pas tout le monde qui regarde les
prix pierre alexandre blouin et le
président de l'association des
détaillants du québec
et qu'est-ce qui est régi qu'est ce qui
ne l'est pas le prix du lait
conventionnel et régis donc le lait sans
ajout semble posséder ultra filtrés par
exemple de l'équipe au biologique non le
lait conventionnel 1% à 2% 3.25 pour les
0% également pour chaque format il y à
un prix minimum et un prix maximum par
exemple pour ce 2 litres de lait 2 % il
ne peut pas être vendu moins de 3
dollars 43 et pas plus de trois dollars
75 dans l'ensemble du québec les prix
fluctuent selon les régions
la loi fixe ou simplement des balais ils
ont soudain dans le québec central si on
veut vous avez des prix plus inférieur
et plus on s'éloigne du centre mais plus
à des prix qui sont bonifiés pour
pouvoir compenser les coûts de
distribution aux accents
au nord du 50e parallèle pas de
réglementation le lait peut être vendue
à n'importe quel prix la régie des
marchés agricoles et alimentaires reçoit
quelques centaines de plaintes par année
en ce qui concerne le prix du lait à
montréal c'est le service d'inspection
des aliments qui est chargé de faire
appliquer le règlement nous recevons
j'ai regardé récemment à peu près une
vingtaine de plaintes à ce sujet par
année et à ce moment là si nous recevons
une plainte à cet effet l'inspecteur va
se déplacer va aller au commerce ci a
effectivement s'est fondée que le prix
n'est pas respectée que ce soit le
minimum ou le maximum mais ils vont
commencer par donner un avertissement
légal aux commerçants puis ceci va
générer une demande de suivi ce qui fait
que on va retourner faire une deuxième
vérification et si encore une fois c'est
pour respecter
il pourrait y avoir une poursuite
judiciaire la régie rend l'information
disponible mais si les personnes ne
prennent pas le temps d'aller voir ils
vont se fier sur leurs livreurs
comment vous savez le prix qui est
établi une fois passé le check in our
world of women est clair la régie disent
qu'ils mettent ça sur internet les prix
comme moi je me débrouille en pot sur
internet
mais pour fouiller dans tout ce qu'ils
aiment être maintenant l'internet ne
suis pas capable
je voudrais évidemment pas tant qu'il ya
des commerçants affiliés des commerçants
qui sont plus isolés des opérateurs qui
sont allophones qui ont fait plus de
difficultés à se retrouver dans la
réglementation mais je dirais que le
fournisseur également une responsabilité
lorsque vous vendez un produit un
commerçant j'imagine que vous allez
vérifier de temps en temps c'est
les contraintes de commercialisation
sont respectées autre problème que
l'épicerie a constaté durant cette
enquête c'est un affichage la plupart du
temps inexistant ou erronées dans le
code
wal mart qui a refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue mais qui a précisé par
écrit que le prix affiché sur leur site
internet n'était pas le prix réellement
payés par les consommateurs
effectivement il ya eu un ajustement sur
notre relevé de carte de crédit
après la livraison il s'agirait selon le
géant en alimentation d'un problème
d'affichage informatique
mais cet ajustement n'a pas été
appliquée sur l'ensemble de notre achat
nous avons tout de même payer ces deux
litres de lait plus cher que les prix
réglementaire alors il ne s'agit pas que
d'un problème des charges informatiques
malgré cette réglementation est bien que
nous soyons les plus gros producteur au
pays les québécois sont les canadiens
qui paie le lait le plus cher après les
résidents de l'île du prince édouard
alors à quoi sert cette réglementation
deux visions s'opposent
moi je pense pas que ça serve à grand
chose personnellement
c'est un choix moi j'ai toujours trouvé
qu'on pénalise les familles la
rétrocession taxe peut cacher et c'est
malheureux c'est un peu comme le concept
d'un cartel ont contrôlé prix le plus
possible pour pas les serments perdre le
marché ou trop jouer avec le marché dans
le pétrole on le voit depuis des années
vous savez on l'a vu dans le pays
pendant 14 ans
un des grands avantages qu'on a avec le
prix régie au québec ce qui a moins de
différence entre les prix des différents
formes
on peut retrouver ailleurs quand on va
en ontario à me kattié de l'est on va
être un prix est beaucoup plus petit un
puits pour compenser mais les
détaillants doivent avoir droit aussi le
prix des autres d autres formes encore
de façon tous importants parce que pas
de fourchette de puyoô pas de
réglementation en bout de ligne
au québec on sait qu'on va payer un prix
relativement équivalent pour l'ensemble
des formes encore faut-il que les
commerçants respectent la réglementation
et c'est aux consommateurs de les
surveiller afin de payer le lait selon
les prix établis qui soit dit en passant
ont augmenté plus vite que l'inflation